okay...
~encouraging the fuel to flow faster~ aigh aigh aigh aigh
~air spanking the car~
I might be generating static electricity with all my movement.
I'm trying, You make it go faster!
I'm trying! You make it go faster!
Oh?
Plotting against their highschool.
Ah, it's a damn shame.
No I don't want a receipt, no, I don't want a receipt
No, I don't want a receipt
There, no!
There, no.
Ow! My ass.
ow my ass
Uhh, good news, bad news. Good news; we got Chica here, and you're with me so that's pretty cool
Uh, bad news is we're on the way to Cracker Barrel, but that would normally be good news.
But we're supposed to get there in three hours and 44 minutes. Estimated to get in there at
10:57. Cracker Barrel in Las Vegas closes at 10:00 p.m.
Which is awfully generous for what we're trying to do. But I'm hoping... because it's rush hour right now. It's currently 7:08 which means that
if we're BOOKING it...
if we're booking it
And I mean IF WE'RE BOOKING IT , I'll get through traffic.
and I mean, IF WE'RE BOOOOKING IT. Imma get through traffic
And we really push this bad boy to the best of its abilities. The barrel is gonna be barreling down the highway and we're gonna
get to Cracker Barrel just in time for the barrel to get some barrel in me. chicken and dumplings in me I'm not...
~mumbles~
Seatbelts, all safe? Good. Chica are you ready? *smooching intesifies*
We're gonna make it!
Ooooh I don't know.
OoOoOoh I DoN't KnOw
Why didn't you wake up on time?
No, it wasn't me. No. I didn't that that was not me
I woke up in plenty of time, to do whatever I was doing that you don't need to know about.
~half singing~Slightly illegal maneuvers are logical when you are rushing to Cracker Barrel!
~still singing~ Nobody can stop you from getting what you want!
Which is delicious chicken and dumplings in your butt.
After you've put it in your mouth, and then you digest it and then... That's how poops made. : )
That's how poop's made! *you have been educated*
How fast can you gooo?
Clunk! ~Engine revving increasing~
AaAaAaAaAh
Clock is ticking! Oh come on!!
My life has mostly been a rush.
Uh...
Uh, just ever since I started doing YouTube. But now that I'm kind of like, just adventuring on the van I uh
just ever since I started doing YouTube. But now that I'm kind of like just adventuring out in the van
I.. uuhh...
I don't know.
I Don't know
Things have felt more free an-and it's been pretty good. You know we did that awesome video project...
we did uhh a lot of other things and frankly... this has been nice to be able to get out and go around.
Even though now the stress that I put on myself is a stress that is self-imposed.
Even though it was self-imposed before - but either way it's good to get out and it's good to be
Having...
Having....
having uuh...
objectives that you only set for yourself. But I'm only going fifty?!?
~yelling in exasperation~
AAAH
COME ON BARREL COME ON!!
But I'm hoping maybe maybe Las Vegas is in a different like time zone than where we are right now.
And if that's true then we cross over into the barrier to Nevada.
We'll be able to get into a different... in the PAST and then we'll have two minutes.
Which is MORE than enough time than I need to cram them chicken and dumplings down my gullet and have a good meal.
Isn't that right bubs? Chica Chica can do it in one minute!
I don't know. I've  just been able to hang out with my friends more.
I've been able to think about like just the creative
behind the WHY of the videos you know?
behind the why of the videos you know
The why of making things and, and
It's something that I don't often get to talk about even in the videos themselves. So it's nice to be able to talk to...
So it's nice to be able to talk to you about it. You know person to person.
you about it. You know person to person. Oh you got a snack there?
Oh you got a snack there? What you get?
What you get?
Ahh, that's cool!
SIXTY? ~Yells in exasperation~
SIXTY?!?
~Engine revving up~
God that's that ah ah God Oh
OH FUUUUUUUUUUUuUuUuU
FaaaaaaaaaAAAaaaAAAAAAAA
Made a slight error, but hey GPS has already compensated for it. We're...
Made a slight error, but hey GPS has already compensated for it. We're
uh...
uuuhhh
still on target! We're uh eh two minutes two minute delay. That's not that bad. We missed an exit
That's fine happens to anybody. Could happen to anybody! But why does it only happen WHEN I'M IN A HURRY!?
But why does it only happen WHEN I'M IN A HURRY. I need my dumps!
I need my dumps
~Slurping~
(slurp)
No, it's okay, I appreciate it
(moany fist bump noise)
Thanks
Good news. We're making good time. We're already estimated to be there 1058 so
Good news. We're making good time. We're already estimated to be there 10:58 so...
(mark makes strange noise)
Judging by the trajectory of the amount of time we're saving over the period of with which we're going.
We should get there just in time, but I wanted to talk about something else before I get go- (makes noises)
goooouuuuhaaaaaaaaaaaahuuuuuu
Change lanes?
change lanes?
This is very dangerous, probably..
Very dangerous probably.
Very dangerous probably.So, I've been having more thoughts about live-streaming you know
So I've been having more thoughts about live-streaming you know
I uh... I just feel like I wanna live stream more and and not that I'm sick of Let's Plays
that's not what it is. I love gaming. Gaming has been a big part of my life since I was a kid.
I want to do more of it. Like, I want to live stream for a few hours every single day.
And uh I don't know what you think of that, but.. you can let me know.
Like...
Like, I just wanna...
I-  I just wanna... I dunno
I just wanna play games and have that feeling of being
I just wanna play games and have that feeling of being..
in a room with your friends. Hanging out,
laughing at a game,
or screaming at a game or getting frustrated or whatever it is.
I just want to feel like it's more real.
And I want to do it more often than I've been doing in the past because, what I imagine is
I'm gonna livestream for about two hours
Everyday starting about 10:00 a.m.. Go until noon and then just hanging out with you because
I don't know that's what it's always been about and that's what I've always loved about it and..
I never want to let that go
And that's very important to me. But first I'm gonna get some Cracker Barrel
But first I'm gonna go get some Cracker Barrell, so
~giddy grunt~
Anyway, that's just my thoughts for now. How's Chica doing?
I can't exactly look and be safe at the same time.
How ya doin' Bubbo?
~EXPLOSIONS~
How bought a butt scratch for the road?
How 'bought a butt scratch? A safe butt scratch!
A *safe* butt scratch!
~High pitched rumble from rumble strips/sleeper lines~
Aaall righty then?
All righty, then.
Well anyway. That was weird but,
bad news, somehow we haven't made up any time at all. It's now
9:28
And it still says we're gonna get there at 10:56. But I have a thought!
If I call them
and ask politely.
Maybe- number one, maybe they're open later than I think they are. And number two.
And number *two*:
Maybe they're a fan?
And... that...
I don't know, either way I'm gonna,
gonna give it a try.
Hi, my name is Mark I was just wondering what's the latest you can place a "To Go order"?
I would need to be-
Ah, I gotcha, I would need to be there exactly at 10?
So if I was say 45 minutes away and was gonna probably get there 10:15, that's not gonna work?
Ah. Okay. alright. Well, thank you very much.
That is always a possibility. tomorrow is always another day!
Yeah...
Okay, thank... thank you. Bye.
Bye
~Screams~
AAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHH
Siri, navigate to the nearest cliff!
Siri, navigate to the nearest cliff
Siri: "Getting directions to the cliffs at Peace Canyon."
Ah
A peaceful death!
~Jazzy background piano music~
~Crash sound & Rooster's morning crow.~
(rooster crowing)
~Triumphant tune~
~Music stops~
We can get another!
We can get another
~Triumphant music resumes~
Wow!
Can't believe we finally did it.
It's been like two weeks since the last time I had Cracker Barrel.
I've never gone that long between Barrel runs before but
This has been a lot of fun. It's such a cool experience to be able to do this with you,
so I'm glad you were along for the ride. Thanks so much and I do want to do more um...
I got a whole bunch of ideas for more creative stuff. Not that going to get Cracker Barrel in a van that you buy
for the exclusive chance to go get Cracker Barrel
uh isn't
incredibly original
But you know I got a lot of other ideas that I want to do. A lot of fun stuff that I want to try
And uh, that doesn't mean that I let go of anything else that I've done before, like
I still love playing video games, I still love making sketches. I still love doing cool stuff, but
I always want to make videos that I'm happy with. And I always want to make things that I'm proud of.
And and I want to make things that
that are always worth your time, you know
even if there is something as simple as going to get Cracker Barrel.
Sometimes the littlest things can mean the most and that's amazing.
So..
Thank you so much for watching and let me know what adventure we should take next
And as always, I will see you in the next video.
I will see you in the next video (look at Chika, she's so cute in the back!)
Bye-bye
Subtitles by volunteers from YouTube.
Subtitles by (and for) the Markiplier community